Well,
it also gets to some really deep places psychologically.
Um,
there's,
there's some,
there's a weirdness to it,
right?
There's a weirdness to sending text,
particularly at anonymously,
you know,
and there's so many accounts that are just an egg,
so many accounts where they're clearly designed.
If you get,
like sometimes someone will tweet something mean to me and I'm like,
hm,
I wonder what this person's up to.
So I go to their site and it's just them tweeting mean shit at people all day
long.
Like it's probably some angry person at work and they're like,
I'm just going to find people and fuck with them all day.
Yup.
When did you realize,
or when did you realize,
I'm sure you're aware of it and when did you realize that this was almost out of
your control in terms of like the scale of it?
Uh,
there were,
there,
there wasn't,
there wasn't one moment.
There wasn't one moment that,
um,
it just felt completely resonant.
Uh,
it's just,
it's,
it's unfolded into the next thing and the next use case and it just keeps
surprising us with how people are using it.
Wheat,
you know,
it definitely.
Um,
recently I think we've identified some of the areas of the service that we need
to pay a lot more attention to.
Um,
Twitter is unique in that it has two main spaces.
One which is your timeline and those are the people that you follow.
And uh,
you know,
when you follow someone,
they've earned that audience and then it has this other world where anyone can
insert themselves into the conversation,
they can actually mention you and you'll see that without asking for it.
You can insert yourself into hashtags and to a search.
Um,
and these are areas that people have taken advantage of and these are the areas
that people have gained our systems to in some cases artificially amplified,
but also just to spread a lot of things that weren't possible with the velocity
that they're not possible before.
Now,
when this is all happening,
what's the conversation like at Twitter when you recognizing that this is
happening,
that people are kind of gaming the system?
Like what,
how do you guys,
how do you mitigate it?
What,
what's the discussion?
Well,
early on it was,
um,
it was pretty surface level.
Like how do we change some of the APP dynamics?
But more recently we're trying to go a lot deeper in and asking ourselves a
question when people open Twitter,
what are we incentivizing?
What are we telling them to do when they open up this app?
We may not explicitly be doing that,
but there's something that we're saying without,
um,
being as clear about it.
So what does the like button incentivize?
What does the retweet incentivize?
What does the number of followers and making that number big,
bold,
incentivize?
So
I'm not sure what we should know.
I'm not sure if we should incentivize anything,
but we need to understand what that is.
And I think,
you know,
right now we,
we do incentivize a lot of echo chambers because we don't make it easy for
people to follow interests and topics.
It's only accounts we incentivize,
um,
a lot of outrage and how hot takes,
because of the,
some of the dynamics in the service.
Not allowing a lot of nuance in conversation earlier on.
Um,
um,
pseudonyms,
uh,
this,
ability to not use your real name incentivizes some positive things like allows
for whistleblowers and journalists to,
uh,
might fear for their career or even worse their life and under certain regimes,
but also allows for people like the example you mentioned of just random fire
and,
uh,
you know,
spread of abuse and harassment throughout.
So those are the things that we're looking at and how do we,
how do we enable more of the conversation to evolve?
How do we increase the credibility,
reputation of accounts?
Um,
how do we identify a credible voices within a particular domain?
I'm not just through this very coarse grain,
blue verified badge.
But,
uh,
if you're an expert in a particular topic,
how do we recognize that in real time and show that so that we can provide more
context to who you're talking to and if you want to engage in a deeper
conversation or just ignore mute or block them.